Zendaya's gonna leave his ass I'm just  her High part of me is gonna get the  best of her I'm sorry Zendaya's like a  sweetheart she doesn't drink  um she she lives with her parents I'm  pretty sure like she's like oh no but  now she's doing those weird acting roles  Hollywood always ruins the sweet kids  well she's now I'll say she's naturally  sweetheart and I think a lot of like  high value men are going to be  interested in her it's not that Tom  Holland isn't a high value man he is but  I just think more high value men are  going to be interested and I think she's  gonna go for it at some point it's you  know it's just like yeah  um I give it six months